in the last video we defined the notion
of a determinant of a 2 by 2 matrix so
if I have some matrix let's just call it
B if my matrix B looks like the if it's
as if its entries are a b c d we defined
the determinant of b the determinant of
b which could also be written as b with
these lines around it which could also
be written as the entries of the
matrices of the matrix with those lines
run a CD and i don't wait to get
confused this is the matrix when you
have the brackets this is the
determinant of the matrix when you just
have these straight lines and this by
definition was equal to ad minus bc and
you saw in the last video or maybe you
saw in the last video what the
motivation for this came from when we
figured out the inverse of B we
determined that it was equal to the
inverse of B was equal to 1 over ad
minus BC times another matrix which was
essentially these two entries swapped so
you got a DNA and then these two entries
made negative so minus C and minus B
this was the inverse of B and we said
well when is this defined this is
defined as long as this character right
here does not equal 0 so said hey this
looks pretty important let's call this
thing right there the determinant let's
call this right here the determinant
determinant and then we could say that B
is invertible invertible if and only if
if and only if the determinant of B the
determinant of B does not equal 0
because if it equals 0 then your your
this formula for your inverse won't be
well-defined we just got this from our
technique of creating an Augmented
matrix what not but the big takeaway is
we define this notion of a determinant
for a 2 by 2 matrix now the next
question at is well what you know that's
just a 2 by 2 everything we do in linear
algebra we like to generalize it to
higher numbers of rows and columns so
the next step at least let's just do
baby steps let's start with a 3 by 3
let's
fine what its determinant is so let me
construct a 3x3 matrix here let's say my
matrix a is equal to let me just write
its entries first row first column first
row second column first row third column
and you have a 2 1 a 2 2 a 2 3 and you
have a 3 1 third row first column a 3 2
and then a 3 3 that is a three by three
matrix right clearly three rows and
three columns this is three by three I
am going to define I am going to define
the determinant of a I'm going to define
so this is a definition I'm going to
define the determinant of this three by
three matrix a as being equal to and
this is a little bit convoluted but
you'll get the hang of it eventually in
the next several videos we're just going
to do a ton of determinants so it just
becomes a bit of second nature to you
it's a little computationally intensive
sometimes but it equals this first row
it equals a 1 1 times the determinant of
the matrix you get if you get rid of
this guy's column and row so if you get
rid of this guy's column and row you're
left with this matrix here so times the
determinant of the matrix a 2 2 a 2 3 a
3 2 and then a 3 3 just like that so
that's our first entry and that's a plus
this and then I said this a plus this
because the next entry is going to be a
minus you have a minus this guy right
here
so then you're going to have minus minus
a 1 to a 1 2 times the matrix you get if
you eliminate his column in his row so
times you're going to get that these
entries right there so a 2 1 a 2 1 a 2 3
a 2 3 a 3 1 a 3 1 and then you have a 3
3 a 3 3 we're not quite done you could
probably guess what the next one's going
to be you're going to have a plus plus
let me switch to a better color Plus
this guy
plus a13 times the determinant of its I
guess you could call it its sub-matrix
we'll call it that for now so this
matrix right here so a 2 1 a 2 1 a 2 2 a
3-1 a 3-2 this is our definition of the
determinant of the determinant of a 3x3
matrix and the motivation is because
when you when you take the determinant
of a 3x3 it turns out I haven't shown it
to you yet that the property is the same
that if the determinant of this is 0 you
will not be able to find an inverse and
when I define determinant in this way
the determinant is not equal 0 you will
be able to find an inverse so that's
where this came from and I haven't just
haven't shown you that yet and I might
not show you because it's super
computationally it'll take a long time
it'll be very hairy and I'll make
careless mistakes but the motivation
comes from the exact same place as the
2x2 version but I think what you
probably want to see right now is at
least just up this thing applied to an
actual matrix because this looks all
abstract right now but if you redo it
with an actual matrix you'll actually
see it's not not too bad so let's leave
the definition up there and let's say
that I have the matrix I have the matrix
1 2 4 2 2 minus 1 3 & 4 0 1 so by our
definition of a determinant the
determinant of this guy right here the
determinant of this guy's let's say I
call that matrix let's call that C C is
equal to that so if we want to figure
out the determinant of C the determinant
of C is equal to I take this guy right
here so let me take that 1 times the
determinant of let's just call it the
sub matrix right here so we have a minus
1 minus 1 we have a sorry
we have a minus 1 got to be careful we
have a 3 we have a 0 and we have a 1
just like that notice I got rid of this
guy's column and this guy's row and I
was just left with minus 1 3 0 1 minus 1
3 0 and 1 next I take this guy I take
this guy and this is U this is the trick
you have to alternate signs if you start
the positive year this next one is going
to be a minus so you're going to have
minus two times
the sub-matrix we can call it if we get
rid of this guy's column and this guy's
row so two three or one so two three
four one I just blanked this out if I if
I could videotape my finger I would
cover my finger over this column right
here and over that row and you just see
a 2 a 3 a 4 and a 1 and that's what I
put right there and then finally we'll
have plus we went plus minus plus so
finally we'll have plus 4 times the
determinant of the sub-matrix if you get
rid of that row in that column so 2
minus 1 4 0 2 minus 1 4 and 0 now these
are pretty straightforward
these are not too bad to compute let's
actually do it so this is going to be
equal to 1 times what minus 1 times 1
let me just write it out minus 1 times 1
minus 0 times 3 this just comes from the
definition of a 2 by 2 determinant we've
already defined that and then we're
going to have a minus 2 minus 2 times 2
times 1 2 times 1 minus 4 times 3 and
then finally we're going to have a plus
4 times 2 times 0 2 times 0 minus minus
1 minus 1 times 4 minus minus 1 times 4
I wrote it all out so you can see these
are just this thing right here is just
this thing right here and then you have
the 4 out front this thing right here
was just this thing right here it's just
a determinant of the 2x2 sub matrix for
each of these guys and if we compute
this this is equal to C minus 1 times 1
is minus 1 minus 0 that's 0 so this is a
minus 1 times 1 so that's a minus 1 and
then we get what is is equal to this is
this right here is 12 so you get 2 minus
12 right you get 2 times 1 minus 4 times
3 2 times so it's minus 10 so that is
equal to minus 10 and then you have a
minus
times a minus two so that becomes a plus
20 right minus 2 times minus 10 and then
finally in the green we have 2 times 0
that's just a 0 and then you have minus
1 times 4 which is minus 4 then you have
a minus side here so it's plus 4 and
then 4 so this all becomes a plus 4 plus
4 times 4 is 16 so plus 16 and what do
we get when we add this up we get 20 20
plus 16 minus 1 it is equal to 35 we're
done we found the determinant of our 3x3
matrix not too bad not too bad right
there so that is equal to the
determinant the determinant of C so the
fact that this isn't 0 tells you that c
is invertible so we know that c is
invertible invertible in the next video
we'll let's try to extend this to n by n
square matrices